bienvenidos al espacio cultural de
france 24 para el programa de hoy
hubiéramos preferido otro arranque uno
en el que el mayor atentado terrorista
de la historia fuera en todo caso una
ficción a la vez en memoria de aquellos
cuatro ataques de hace 20 años no ha
faltado arte y su registro es nuestra
contribución
al ser reciente entre fines de 2001 y
2002 a lo más que los creadores usaron
llegar fue a lo plástico en honor a
quienes saltaron o cayeron de las torres
gemelas eric fisher ideó esta escultura
en bronce en alusión a la vulnerabilidad
pero ni así ni pareciéndose a la nube
que una década más tarde haría
christopher saucedo en recuerdo de su
hermano bombero y the world trace center
no estuvo exento de críticas por ello el
cine no sólo le tocó borró de su
derribado skyline el caso más notorio
fue el recorte de spider-man sino que se
las ingenió para pasar de los solemnes
del freno la industria a reforzar el
patriotismo y el peligro de enemigos
como al qaeda
[Música]
un día horrible un día trágico y sobre
todo las repercusiones de ese día fueron
más trágicas porque sabemos lo que pasó
en afganistán y en irak pero nuestras
libertades civiles fueron recortadas en
eeuu
si ves cualquier película que haya
salido en eeuu después del 11 de
septiembre cualquier persona morena es
el villano afortunadamente y yo creo que
es así la mayoría de los estadounidenses
ya no se sienten de esa manera nos
consideramos a nosotros mismos más como
personas del mundo en lugar de
aislacionistas
ante este discurso propaganda es la
palabra que viene a la mente sin embargo
la creación de estas cintas series y
documentales de entretenimiento
educativos también sirvieron como
recuerdo y sanación propia
en muchas formas artísticas de nuestra
cultura provienen de años y experiencias
traumáticas pienso en el blues el jazz
el gospel también en todo el arte que
surgió en los murales tras el 11 de
septiembre estos sirven como señales
visuales que nos recuerdan curación y
tal vez nuestra valentía sin embargo
reconozco que a algunas personas les
puede recordar la pérdida y solo la
pérdida que experimentaron para otros es
en cambio un recuerdo lejano y ver una
película del 11-s es sólo arte
exploración y empatía si el 11-s de 2001
fue un antes y un después global con
consecuencias en el afganistán actual
2006 abrió la puerta a un recuerdo
distinto al margen de la guerra de irak
recordarán el emotivo filme de oliver
stone sobre los implicados en las tareas
de rescate y limpieza de la zona 0 en
orden aparecieron a sí mismos los
relatos del disidente michael moore
fahrenheit nine eleven se ganó en 2004
la palma de oro en cannes y nos quitó
las vendas tratando las causas y el uso
gubernamental de los atentados el
director de la saga bourne paul
greengrass se metió dentro de los vuelos
suicidas secuestrados mientras que en la
oscarizada katherine bigelow indagó en
la cia y su búsqueda del paradero del
líder osama bin laden
con agua
es de este modo que llegamos a un
aniversario bastante audiovisual con
documental de style y next bio que tiene
como epicentro los testimonios y
secuelas de los neoyorquinos además de
outsider acerca del tributo memorial and
museum y los desafíos de su director
creativo michael sulland que tras el
terrorismo que dio paso a la guerra
estadounidense más larga hizo de su
estudio un lugar de fotografías
colectivas
aún con estas piezas turningpoint punto
de inflexión y words son nuestras
grandes apuestas ambas de de félix la
primera reconstruye al dedillo desde la
invasión soviética en terreno afgano
hasta la lucha contra el terror y el
retiro de este agosto con archivos
inéditos sobrevivientes y audios de los
organismos de seguridad aunque es con la
segunda que nos frenamos por su punzante
vigencia
su relato apela el respeto y sobriedad
comentados pero dos décadas después
aborda en dolorosos cuántos muertos hubo
y en cuanto se cifró cada vida qué
precio le pondrían a una perdida así
michael keaton hace del perito que se
ofreció a lograr un fondo de
compensación de víctimas que evitará el
tesoro ya toda la economía
estadounidense enfrentar los juicios de
las casi 3.000 familias afectadas esto
que no deja de ser criticable se topa
con la frialdad del abogado y la cruzada
indirecta de charles stanley tucci
demostrarle que su fórmula era injusta y
pagaba el silencio de cada demanda el
fondo que todavía rige y ya cuenta 67
mil solicitudes informó que las muertes
ligadas a la inhalación de humo tóxico
superaron los fallecidos de ese día y
esa vertiente está junto a la pregunta
no planteada de que hacíamos esa jornada
en la que el mundo se paró
y
en el informe del censo es habilidad
para vender unos reproches bueno hombres
gay fútbol de excursión 90 vendados en
ese sentido los nombres en especie y un
estado de ansiedad
si bien nuestro enfoque 11-s ha sido
cinéfilo marvel comics lo transforma
también en un tributo doble al bombero
al policía al médico a los voluntarios
anónimos que son los verdaderos héroes
de una tragedia de la que más del 40% de
los fallecidos no se han identificado
aún formalmente y en la que la música
sufrió una autocensura de temas sobre
aviones y géneros como el punk y el rock
hasta aquí llegamos por hoy muchísimas
gracias por su apoyo a la cultura y
hasta muy pronto cuídense
[Música]
cómo